MaMartine Biron, Michel C. Auger
PaPaul Journet, bonsoir.
- - (ensemble) Bonsoir
- - Alors, où vous en êtes dans
vovotre analyse de l'utilité. Vs
avavez vu ces images, ces march,
ceces commentaires, cette parole
ququ'on entend davantage. Cette
jojournée la vérité de la
réréconciliation. Martine,
apapparaît après la réaction de
MoMonsieur Legault, mais d'abord
totour de table sur aujourd'hui,
c'c'était une journée comme ça.
- - Je trouve que c'est
exextrêmement utile. Ce témoigne
auaujourd'hui, j'ai trouvé ça
inintéressant. La diversité de s
tétémoignages. Cela fait longtes
quque je couvre les affaires
auautochtones travers les époqu,
dadans l'Ouest au Québec. Je me
rerends compte qu'il y a eu des
papas de géants qui ont été fai.
LeLes gens sont beaucoup plus
coconscients de la question
auautochtone. C'est un dossier i
esest complexe, qui n'est pas
fafacile a comprendre, mais on
cocomprend mieux tous les jourst
leles langues se délient et on
sesent aussi que les communautés
AuAutochtones commencent, les
liliens commencent a s'établir.
- - Je souligne trois fois ce qe
vovous venez de dire. Le lien de
coconfiance commence a s'établi.
LeLes autochtones passent
gogouvernement, face a la socié.
- - Madame Monet disait que les
momots des lettres candidats
auautochtones c'était alcooliqu,
sasale, drogués. C'était inchané
papar rapport a fait une bonne
chchose. Donc là amplement
cocommencé a réglé les problèmes
enentre autres le territoire va
êêtre bien compliqué mais on pet
pepenser que le réglé. Et avoir
unune journée par année pour
pepenser a ces choses, c'est de
cacapable de prévoir une arène
lilittéraire imagine que c'est n
susujet assez important pour lui
dodonner une journée aussi par
anannée.
- - Paul.
- - L'importance de la journée t
asassez facile a démontré. On a
paparlé depuis plusieurs minutes
enen ce moment et l'éducation la
coconnaissance est importante ms
onon est encore très loin. Même
cecertains préjugés diminuent
peperdre de leur intensité, la
méméconnaissance est encore très
grgrande pour toutes sortes de
raraisons. Entre autres aussi
paparce que les médias on est ds
leles grands centres urbains.
CoComme la majorité de la
popopulation. On est très loin s
didifférentes communautés, des
didifférentes nations. Même si s
pepersonnes de bonne foi, ne sot
papas beaucoup en contact avec
dédéjà des premières nations. Et
auaussi quand on parle de
réréconciliation, c'est un mot
tetellement immense qu'il donne
prpresque le vertige. Je crois e
çaça va peut-être prendre une
gégénération. On se demande paùu
cocommencer. C'est pourtant de
écécouté entre autres d'écoutere
trtravail déjà fait part toutes
leles commissions qui ont pondu
dedes rapports pour lesquels ily
a a peut-être pas eu suffisammet
dede suite.
- - Inévitablement, Michel C. Vs
susuivez la depuis assez
lolongtemps, vous le savez.
InInévitablement va revenir avec
JeJean Chrétien voulait faire
ététais un ministre. C'est-à-die
l'l'abolition de cette loi sur s
InIndiens et reprogrammer une
rerelation entre les nations
auautochtones et le Canada les
prprovinces.
- - Ne pas être capable depuis
l'l'abolir la loi sur les Indies
n'n'a pas été capable de se mete
d'd'accord les autochtones non
plplus ne pas être capable de se
memettre d'accord.
- - Les autochtones c'est bien
bebeau si on enlève la loi sur s
InIndiens, mais on ne veut pas
totout perdre non plus. Ça va êe
cocomplexe mais ça n'est pas
ininévitable Martine?
- - chaque chose en son temps. e
pipignon public et prend
coconscience de ce qu'est la lo,
dedeux ou on s'en va, plus
rararement avec les communautés
auautochtones. C Ce qui n'étaits
lele cas avant. C'est un dossier
ququi est très difficile a
cocomprendre. Par exemple, nousu
QuQuébec on a vécu la crise
auautochtone. Était sur la crise
auautochtone. 90, les gens était
asassez amers allés garder
auautochtones. Aujourd'hui les
chchoses ont évolué. Parce que
d'd'autres autochtones de d'auts
cocommunautés ont expliqué ce
ququ'ils ont vécu. C'est là que
trtranquillement l'opinion
pupublique commence a mieux
cocomprendre l'enjeu par exemple
dedes pensionnats, comprendre ou
onon s'en va et va ramener avec
leles autochtones et faire
prpression sur les gouvernements
popour que les choses changent.
- - Très bien. Monsieur Legault
ququi a parlé de cela et qui a
prpresque demandé brûle pourpoi,
paparce que congé férié, la
plplupart des promesses non
adadoptées. Le dernier quelques
prprovinces: je questionne la
NoNouvelle-Écosse.
- - On doit se rappeler de ce
ququi est arrivé entre autres
dadans les pensionnats. C'est
teterrible. Et puis, on doit
s's'en souvenir à chaque année
etet c'est bon qu'on ait
unune journée de commémoration.
STSTEVEN GUILBEAULT, ministre
dudu Patrimoine canadien
- - Que le premier ministre
LeLegault soit incapable
dede quelque empathie que ce sot
enenvers tous ces gens-là,
c'c'est, en tant que québécois..
çaça me sidère.
E Et je souhaite que mon premir
miministre du Québec soit capabe
àà l'avenir de faire preuve
dede beaucoup plus d'empathie
etet de compréhension envers
leles peuples autochtones
dudu Québec et de partout au pa.
- - On a entendu plus tôt dans
l'l'émission, Monsieur Legault t
rerevenu, il a expliqué ne pouvt
papas ajouter a conduit Perrier
cocomme ça, etc. Ce qui était
peperçu sur le coup et ça été
enenvoyé vous le savait avec les
réréseaux, c'est un manque de
sesensibilité.
- - Je vais dire deux choses.
D'D'abord il y a deux façons de
vovoir. Si on regarde l'arbre,
c'c'est ce que les réactions ont
étété très vives dépenses de
popositions qui ont souligné le
mamanque de sensibilité.
LaLa deuxième fois dans la semae
MoMonsieur Legault manque de
sesensibilité ce qui a trait la
ququestion autochtone. Début dea
sesemaine, la perte de questions
lolorsqu'on commémore la déessee
JoJoyce Echaquan. Regarde la fot
enen entier, on se rend compte e
MoMonsieur Legault, de quelque
chchose avec Monsieur Legault.
MaMais peut-être que depuis le
dédébut de la session.
MoMonsieur Legault SpaceX prépae
bebeaucoup. La vu pendant la cre
dede la pandémie. Il faisait ses
momots. Mais quand on écoute
atattentivement la séquence cale
dadans le corridor, ce n'était s
prpréparé ce qu'il a dit. Alors
ququ'est-ce qui se passe avec
MoMonsieur Legault?
unune qui, dans ses proches
coconseillers. Quelque chose qui
clcloche.
- - Michel.
- - Deux choses là-dessus. La
grgrande force Monsieur Legaultn
plplus être quelqu'un de
sysympathique c'est d'avoir de
l'l'empathie. Hélas, il était tt
sasauf empathique. Lui répondren
didisant on a besoin de plus de
prproductivité et passe notre
jojournée de congé n'était pas a
bobonne réponse. Pas aujourd'hui
n'n'est pas demain non plus.
DeDeuxième, c'est que Monsieur
GuGuilbault. Un coup de coude de
lala ligue nationale. Voici le
nonouveau ton des relations
féfédérales et provinciales a
papartir de maintenant.
- - Je suis content que vous
didisiez ça.
- - Les élections sont passées
n'n'est pas passées comme burnot
ouou Hadopi et M. O'Toole. Les
chchoses vont changer c'est
ininévitable.
- - Il cherchait un micro. Avan,
onon n'aurait pas entendu cela
d'd'un ministre fédéral libéral
cocontre Monsieur Legault. Il ny
a a rien qui va être laissez-
papasser.
- - Rien de gratuit.
- - Entre laquelle la vengeance
esest un plat qui se mange fauxt
frfraîchement sorti du four. C't
pepeut-être un peu bizarre de la
papart de Monsieur Guilbault.
QuQuébec n'est pas la seule
prprovince qui n'en fait pas un
cocongé férié. L'Ontario,
l'l'Alberta et je crois aspect
égégard de nouveaux produits. Je
nene pense pas que la chose a
fafaire de la réconciliation de
popoursuivre les guerres
popoliticiennes. Cela dit, je ne
MoMonsieur Legault, souvenez-vos
àà la fois de la dernière sessin
paparlementaire, promettait d'êe
plplus saine et ce n'est pas trs
bibien parti. Le problème cette
sesemaine. Son est d'accumulatin
dede réaction HO où il manque un
pepeu de hauteur. Je crois que e
popositionné d'Écosse depuis
lolongtemps en voulant en fairen
dédébat sur le thème racisme
sysystémique ou d'un autre term.
MaMais hieier la journée de poue
papas répondre a la position mas
prprendre prétexte de leur
ququestion adressée aux premièrs
nanations. Ces comportent deux
sesemaines, c'est un devrait
paparler. Pas les utiliser comme
prprétexte pour prolonger les
guguerres partisanes.
- - On le sent tendu, on est das
unune logique quasi électorale
avavec Québec solidaire, avec ls
lilibéraux. Ce qui a été absent
cecette semaine, c'est un peu de
hahauteur. Les pressions de loin
ilil y a comme un égarement un
pepeu.
- - Au lieu de mettre son chapeu
dede premier ministre, parce que
c'c'est sûr que les partis
d'd'opposition veulent se
dédémarquer. Il cherche le chemn
popour y aller. C'est ce que les
ququestions et les réactions sot
totoujours empreintes de
pepersonnes. Monsieur Legault an
dedevoir que les autres n'ont p.
DeDe mettre son chapeau de premr
miministre et non passer dans le
bobox de chef de la et c'est ce
ququ'il a fait. Aujourd'hui, one
sesent un peu essoufflé parce qe
lala question autochtone le
prpréoccupe Monsieur Legault, ps
enen ce qu'il est plus question
teterre-à-terre de terrain. Quad
JoJoyce Echaquan est décédé il a
unun an, il a prie le taureau pr
leles cornes. C'est politiquemet
ququ'il devait faire quelque
chchose. La son vice-ministre, l
a a dit remettre vIO en place un
rarapportVies. Il sait que c'est
imimportant. Aujourd'hui,
auaujourd'hui n'était pas sur sn
écécran.
- - Avec les communautés Innues,
ilil essaie de progresser mais e
n'n'est pas sa meilleure semain.
- - Monsieur Dubé qui veut, il a
anannoncé puis on ne reviendra s
llà-dessus, votre belle et salle
dede spectacle de ce monde vont
popouvoir être remplie a craqué
mamais avec le masque. Mais la
MoMonsieur Dubé vu que les dépus
dodonnent l'exemple. Le passepot
vavaccinal soit obligatoire chez
vovous dans les corridors de
l'l'Assemblée nationale. Début s
pepersonnel et tout.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet des Services sociaux, Québc
- - Ce qu'on demande à tout
lele monde, je ne comprends pas,
hhônettement, puis je vais
ararrêter ma réponse là,
jeje ne comprends pas que les
paparlementaires ne veulent pas
dodonner l'exemple aux Québécoi.
JeJe pense que c'est beaucoup ps
unune décision politique qu'une
dédécision de santé publique.
JeJe pense qu'on devrait donner
l'l'exemple. Il y a assez
dede gens au Québec qui se sont
foforcés depuis un an et demi.
JeJe ne vois pas pourquoi
leles parlementaires ne feraient
papas l'effort de donner l'exeme
auaux Québécois.
- - Pourquoi ne passe pas ça
d'd'après vous Paul?
nonotre des réserves de montre
l'l'exemple en exigeant le
papasseport vaccinal.
- - Je cherche sans trouver
popourquoi ce ne passe pas. Ce e
MoMonsieur Dubé a raison. Au-deà
dedes grands calculs de santé
pupublique, il y a aussi des
dédécisions politiques et
sysymboliques devraient être
prprises au moment où cet autome
dedemande au personnel soignant
d'd'avoir ces deux doses, et aui
ouoù on songe a le faire pour ls
enenseignants, ce qui serait une
bobonne idée me semble-t-il, c't
lala moindre des choses
l'l'Assemblée nationale impose a
mmême contrainte.
- - Québec solidaire est contre.
LeLe PQ est contre, les libéraux
sosont pour.
- - Le PQ et QS CDC la maison du
pepeuple, alors le peuple devrat
avavoir accès sa maison comme il
lele veut. Mais le peuple n'a ps
acaccès actuellement. Tu ne peux
papas entrer effectuer un
vivisiteur. Les gradins la perte
dede questions sans vie : les
cocommissions parlementaires, sr
leles invités peuvent y assiste.
LeLe peuple est absent.
- - On sent que Dubé ça l'agace.
LeLes bêtises accordée passeport
vavaccinale dans les restaurant.
- - La flexion entre la santé
pupublic et le politique. J'ai u
HoHoracio Arruda qui dit-moi, je
nene me suis pas prononcé là-
dedessus. Pour Québec solidaire
dadans le Bourget, ils disent
nonous, on écoutait la science.
- - Il y a aussi un côté sanitae
llà-dedans. C'est en utilisant
AsAssemblée nationale. Le Centre
BeBell peut être pelé pourquoi s
l'l'Assemblée nationale. Les ges
ququi veulent aller voir une
séséance Assemblée nationale une
cocommission parlementaire devrt
popouvoir montrer leur passeport
vavaccinal sans trop de problèm.
JeJe ne vois pas la difficulté
mamajeure de cela je ne vois pas
d'd'enjeu démocratique.
- - Position aussi un peu parlée
d'd'elle. Problème de hauteur.
- - Là-dessus, vous avez raison
PaPaul. De la suivre. Notez que
HoHoracio Arruda a dit aujourd'i
quque l'automne se passe beaucop
mimieux que lui-même l'avait
prprévu. C'est intéressant.
- - Oui, mais je ne pense pas qe
çaça a un lien direct. Ça explie
popourquoi Monsieur Dubé s'est
avavancé un petit peu en
cocommençant a parlé à une èreùu
lele port du masque ne serait ps
rerequis partout. J'ai rendez-vs
avavec nation des cinq a 11 ans
ququi pourraient commencer début
nonovembre. On reste avoir quel
popourcentage de gens se serait
vavacciné. J'ai rendez-vous
vavacciné.
- - J'ai rendez-vous pour moi sa
lulundi. Merci beaucoup a vo